just when I thought that all hope for
new Max was lost Mark German comes out
and saves the day yes that's right he's
expecting a huge Mac launch at the end
of this month but the most unusual part
of it all is that he's actually
considering the possibility of Apple
updating the high-end MacBook Pros again
in the same year with M3 Pro and M3 Max
chips so in this video I'm going to
break down why I think it makes much
more sense for Apple to give us a more
Syle update for the 24in iMac and call
it good but before I get into that I've
got to talk about the roller coaster of
leaks from Mark Gman recently in my
theory on how all of this happened back
in July Mark Gman believed that new M3
chip Max would be coming sometime in the
fall but unfortunately earlier this
month he said no the event is no longer
planned and things started to look down
from there and now here we are back to
believing a Max Center event is
happening on October 30th or 31st but
with that said let's get back into the
juicy details about the 24-in iMac and
why I think it just makes sense for this
Mac to get released this month first of
all it's been around 2 and a half years
since the original 24in Apple M1 iMac
was released so it naturally makes sense
for this one to see an update another
reason is that Apple doesn't like
releasing their iMac at the same time as
their other MacBooks and Mac Mini models
since the products sort of take the
spotlight away from each other this
reason alone is why Apple decided to
wait another 6 months to release the
24-in iMac after the original M1 Mac
releases in November of 20120 and now
we've been hearing about the delays for
Apple's M3 chip until early next year so
if they don't release the iMac right now
they might not be able to release it
until much much later next year to avoid
any product release conflicts and issues
with either the new M3 MacBooks or the
Mac Minis and then late next year would
honestly be just too late but now
getting into the even juicier evidence
for the 24-in iMac release we have
rumors from Mark Gman going way back to
February and March saying that the new
iMac was in the advanced stages of
development likely being released as
early as late
2023 which perfectly matches the end of
this month however Mark believes that
this iMac will skip the M2 and come with
the M3 chip but I actually don't agree
based on my belief that Apple always
reveals new M chips in the MacBook Air
first and seeing as the MacBook Air is
getting delayed until next year I don't
think they're going to reveal the M3
first in the iMac instead I'm actually
starting to believe this new leak that
just recently came out according to the
Japanese blog mac aakara Apple will soon
release an iMac with both the M2 and M2
Pro chip options Thunderbolt 4 ports
Wi-Fi 6E and Bluetooth 5.3 support and
their main reasoning is that some custom
24-in iMac configurations are facing up
to 1 month shipping delays but even more
than that they correctly predicted the
recent iPad leaks that we had where some
people claimed that new iPads were
coming while Mac aakara claimed would
just be a new Apple pencil with USBC and
nothing else and yes they were
completely right so I have a feeling
that they have some sort of
knowledgeable sources in this area and
it actually makes complete sense for
this iMac to receive the M2 and M2 Pro
chips right now for four big reasons for
reason number one it's already been 1
year and 4 months since the release of
the M2 Chip and about 9 months after the
release of of the M2 Pro so they need to
release this update now since next year
is going to be all about the M3
generation and what if this iMac has
been sitting somewhere waiting on a
shelf for the perfect time to release
since the beginning of this year but
Apple couldn't release it alongside the
M2 and M2 Pro Mac Mini because that Mac
competes with the iMac and they couldn't
release it at WWDC in June either
because they wanted to give more
attention ition to The Vision Pro
headset and the new 15-in Macbook Air so
the earliest they could realistically
release it is this month even if it's
been ready to launch since the beginning
of the year now for reason number two
Greg from Greg's gadgets had a great
theory about Apple trying to kill off
all of their lightning accessories
before the end of the year which is why
the 24-in iMac would come now to
introduce new USBC magic peripherals for
the iMac including the Magic Mouse the
magic Trackpad and magic keyboard This
actually makes a ton of sense because we
saw the USBC airpods Pro 2 which was a
bit of a weird update since nothing else
changed except for lossless support for
the Vision Pro headset then we got an
even weirder update of the apple pencil
switching to USBC especially since they
decided to update it without releasing
it alongside a new iPad which would have
definitely boosted sales so apple is
making some really interesting choices
in order to rid their store of lightning
products so if that theory is true the
iMac should be coming before the end of
the year likely alongside a new pair of
USBC airpods Max maybe in December now
for reason number three Hatchi the tech
otter was very vocal on Twitter before
WWDC claiming that the 24-in iMac would
absolutely get updated with the M2 Chip
instead of the M3 because Apple
apparently has a massive surplus of M2
chips that didn't sell anywhere near as
well as the M1 chips did that was a huge
part of the reason why we got the 15-in
air with the M2 Chip as well as the
Vision Pro headset coming with M2 to
sell more of those existing Surplus
chips he even said he wouldn't be
surprised if Apple released an Apple TV
like gaming console with the M2 Chip
this year and if we look at the
lackluster sales of Apple's M2 Chip Max
especially the 15-in MacBook ear it
actually starts to make sense and then
finally we have reason number four which
is the absolute best reason of all
remember when we had a ton of new leaks
about color matched USBC to USBC cables
intended for the iPhone 15 launch well
those obviously never showed up since we
got simple white cables for all of the
iPhone 15 models well well Sam Cole from
Apple track recently pointed out that
those new leaked cables actually make a
lot more sense for the iMac since we
already have color matched USBC to
lightning cables for all of the magic
peripherals and these new color matched
cables are USBC to USBC so it's now so
obvious that they're intended for the
iMac and we started seeing them leak
because Apple has been prepping the
release for the end of this month in
order order to phase out lightning so
all of those are the big reasons for why
I believe the 24-in is coming next month
and I know that Mark German talked about
there being a very small chance we could
be seeing the M3 Pro and M3 Max MacBook
Pros get released but I honestly don't
think so there's no way that Apple would
release these updates so close to each
other since we just had it in January 9
months ago so both of them would still
be named
2023 high-end MacBook Pros that would
just be too confusing and it's just too
soon in my opinion and if I'm wrong it
would be a clear signal that apple is
desperate to skip the M2 generation as
fast as possible to help boost max sales
but anyway I have a pretty good feeling
that next week's launch will be the 24in
iMac with both M2 and M2 Pro chips if
you agree with me let me know down in
the comments section below and if you
enjoyed it subscribe above and check out
my other videos like the 12.9 in iPad
Air which is also weird thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
[Music]
video